Good morning Hank, it's Tuesday.
It's currently colder in Indianapolis than it is on most of Mars.
Alright Hank, I got to go. I think Willy's stuck. Free Willy!
Also, I strained my groin, so I'm literally sitting right now on a bag of frozen organic strawberries,
so in general, my life is dominated by cold. Let's talk about warmth.
Los Angeles is warm, that's where they're making The Fault in Our Stars movie. This is the poster,
in case you haven't seen it. I love it. I particularly love it because I can't remember the last time I saw a movie
poster with a female romantic lead who has visible evidence of her physical disability, but is still portrayed
as being able to like, love and be loved, so that's great. Boy, I hope the movie's good.
I haven't seen it yet, but it should be good. Alright, what else makes me feel warm? Mmm, Esther.
So, Hank, Esther Earl was our friend and a Nerdfighter who died of cancer when she was sixteen.
She inspired much of The Fault in Our Stars, but The Fault in Our Stars isn't about her.
This is her actual story. It's an amazing book. Esther was a beautiful writer. I wrote the introduction and other
people wrote other parts, but Esther's parts are the best. I'll read you the first sentence of my introduction.
By the way, there's a link in the dooblydoo. You can preorder it. It comes out January 28th.
"My friendship with Esther Earl began as so many great love stories do, at a Harry Potter convention."
Also, there's a big book launch event on February 1st in Boston with lots of Nerdfighters and Wizard Rockers
and Esther's family. There's a link in the dooblydoo. And it will be live streamed here at
youtube.com/vlogbrothers.
Hmm, what else is warm? American president Millard Fillmore was born this day in 1800. The last thing he
ever ate was one spoonful of warm soup, so that's warm. Oh, and also of course, England in winter
is very warm. What's that? Oh. Well, at least it's dry.
Oh, I see. Okay.
That sucks. But it warms me in the inside to be able to tell you that the Nerdfighter community is now
officially a sponsor of AFC Wimbledon, a football club owned by its fans.
This Saturday, AFC Wimbledon play Torkay? Torquee? Torquay? Torkay? I'm not very good at pronunciation.
Anyway, they play one of the other teams in league two, and our messages will be on the side of the field
and in the program. So Nerdfighters of Kingston and Wimbledon and Greater London,
I hope that you will find a way to go to the game because I think it would be great if there were
Nerdfighter support for the first official Nerdfighter game. There's a link to the location of
Cherry Red Records Stadium in the dooblydoo and if you don't know what I'm talking about,
you should watch this video. So there you have it, Hank. Esther's dream of being a published writer
is really going to come true, and we sponsor a fourth-tier English professional soccer team.
Life in Nerdfighteria continues to be weird and wonderful. Well, sometimes.
Other times, you have to sit on frozen, organic strawberries, but at least they're organic!
No conventionally farmed strawberries for my groin.
Hank, I'll see you on Friday.